hello everyone and welcome back to the
match that we've already covered but we
only covered a game from boar three this
is a game from board one uh fabiano
caruana representing united states
versus another rebecca sator of
representing uzbekistan and as you guys
know abdusatrov is the reigning world
rapid champion uh and the problem is
uzbekistan is losing by uh by a full
point we've already shown the game that
wesley so uh one it was that brilliant
victory in 28 moves uh and now uh notre
back wants to fight back of course but
it's not easy it's against fobby and he
does have the black piece so let's see
what happened in this one as it's uh
well it's just very enjoyable so fabi
has the white pieces and he opens with
d4 we have d5 and bishop to f4 going for
the uh london system uh knight to f6 and
e3 so there were a couple of um
interesting ideas about why fabi would
go for the london system as it's uh you
know he he plays pretty much everything
he doesn't have to prepare
uh as he's better prepared than everyone
else uh but something that they
mentioned during the live commentary is
that rustam kasim janov who was uh
second of fabiana corwana is now um uh
training or rather serves as a trainer
for the olympia for the uzbekistan team
and the fabi might be thinking that he
knows a bit too much about fabi's
preparation maybe he gives them a bit
you know a bit too too much inside so
maybe that's why he decided to mix it up
and but okay the london system is on the
board we have c5 and the knight to f3 we
have knight to c6 and knight beat d2 c
characters on the four e compress on d4
and now bishop to f5 and here uh we have
bishop to b5 so if i be not going for
the standard uh
c3 london he goes for this line that has
been played quite a few times between
some very very strong players for
example uh alireza furuja defeated david
anton guiharo uh levon arunian defeated
ernesto enerkiev and there were a couple
of very interesting games that featured
this bishop the b5 move so here queen to
b6 putting pressure on the bishop and
then now fabi plays c4 yeah this is what
he prepared and it's quite a quite an
interesting and complicated line so d
captures on c4 and now we have pawn to
a4 defending the bishop once again
and now bishop to d3 stopping fabi from
castling we have knight to e5 attacking
the bishop and now attacking the c 4.3
times
and um there are i believe two games
where a6 was played but here we have e6
by abuse and it is now as of move 10 uh
that we have a completely new game uh so
fabi goes queen to f3 he still waits
with the recapture on c4 and rook to c8
getting the rook into the game knight
captures on d3 eliminating the light
squad bishop c captures and now queen
captures and d3 winning back the pawn
with a6 attacking the bishop and now
knight the c4 so these are some of the
complications that uh fabi prepared you
don't have to move the bishop right away
you can go after the queen first but now
bishop to b4 with check with dasha back
to d2 bishop captures on d2 queen
captures on d2 and only now queen back
to c7 uh fabi trades in c6 bishop
captures uh and queen captures on c6 we
have knight to e3 as the knight is
attacked we first have to move it before
castling so knight e3 and the both
players castle so castles castles and
not knight to e4 and this is uh what
fabi got out of the opening it's not all
that much uh
equal material abu satrav's knight a bit
better place than fabi's knight on e3
also he does have full control over the
c file uh but um
uh that well
uh
it's it's fair to assume that fabi knows
the position uh much much better and
there will be a move that um
will be so great uh that uh
i mean you have to have prepared this uh
at home so uh here queen to b4 uh now
putting pressure on that b7 pawn so the
queen can't really leave the c6 square
rook after d8 and now pawn to a5 so now
controlling both of the pawns with the a
pawn knight's the d6 uh remaneuvering
the knight and now rook after d1 we have
knights to b5
putting pressure on the d4 pawn and this
is the move i had in mind here fabi
doesn't want to just wait for
abdusathrov to double up rooks here put
more pressure on this d4 pawn even the
queen can join the action uh and he
plays to d5 he sacrifices the pawn uh
just to win the f5 square
for his knight now the problem is you
have to capture with the pawn if you
play rook captures of course we're just
going to capture the rook so that's out
of the question so the only way to
really enjoy this spawn is to capture it
with the e pawn so e captures on d5 and
now fabi plays knight to f5 and this is
basically what fabi got out of his
opening and preparing the london system
for this game now he has a beautifully
active f5 square for the knight and he's
already threatening knight to e7 check
which will be a monster fork forking
absolutely everything uh but abdusatorov
strikes back incredibly well he plays
queen to c5 now this is a very nicely
defended because if you trade for
example queen captures rook characters
now there is no rook and c8 for you to
fork and also if you try 97 check right
away there's king of f8 this is what
abdul sartrov had in mind and now if
queen captures rook captures there is no
good way to play this the only way to
survive this is to play b4 uh but still
it's not going to be all that great rook
c4 knight captures on the e5 and now
knight to d4 uh
cutting off the rook's defense of the
night now rook captures on d5 is coming
so you have to move it rook captures on
b4 and abdusatro would get to enjoy this
position being up upon against fabi
would it be enough for a win it's hard
to say but it would be a very enjoyable
so instead after queen to c5 fabie goes
queen to h4 of course he doesn't want to
trade queens he sacrificed the pawn for
the attack uh and now we have pawn to f6
uh this is uh
you you don't have to play it but it's
uh
i mean it's uh it definitely comes in
handy uh here abdusatrov's idea is f6 g6
and then he wants to get his king to the
seventh rank because here uh let's say
you try something like um you play king
to h8 uh you you already fall for knight
captures on g7 and now it's very very
difficult for black to play this if fabi
wants he can even just force uh a nice
perpetual here with something like this
so uh of course fabi doesn't want to
force a perpetual but
you know you don't if you don't have to
give him the option better not give him
the option so here f6 and now we have
queen to g4 now just threatening
checkmate
and
again you have to be careful if you
defend it with something like rook to d7
then there are ideas like knight h6
check picking up the rook so uh here
abdul saturn has to play it uh
incredibly precisely rook to c7 is one
nice way to do it just defend it like
this and get everything away from this
diagonal but he goes g6 chases away the
knight knights to d4 and now he trades
off a pair of knights captures captures
and now king to f7 so he did weaken his
king a little bit but it's uh
questionable if fabi can do something
about this fabi starts the attack again
h4 now comes queen to b5 making room for
the
rooks to infiltrate also putting
pressure on the b2 pawn so here just
rook to e1 fabi says uh feel free to
feel free to go after this pawn but if
you capture on b2 then just queen to e6
with check and now you are
you know you're just getting destroyed
so instead rook to e8 we have to counter
that rook on the e file and now rook e
back to d1 fabio of course not
interested in trading he wants as many
attackers as possible as this king is uh
not as safe as fabi's king and g1
so here rook the c4 offering a trade of
rooks now the rook cannot move as the
queen would hang uh and uh here we have
a trade rook captures on c4 d captures
on c for and now fabi again continues
with pushing of the pawn h5 now if queen
captures you can capture on c4 with
check so instead we have g captures on
h5 not being afraid of anything and
queen to f4 now by fabi again having
access to h6 having access to c7
uh so it could be very dangerous for
example queen c7 check then if the row
comes to d7
you you get the picture so here king to
g6 now comes queen to c7 and rook to e4
now
we have queen to c8 uh now with ideas of
delivering some back rack chunks uh back
rank checks and now rook to ea chasing
back the queen queen c7 and now rook to
e4 so will we see a repetition here uh
abdul satorov says i'm not so sure fabi
does repeat queen to see it but now
queen to be for putting pressure on that
e1
uh square but also now the queen now has
very nice access to the e7 if needed uh
and here we have kink the h2 by fabi
yeah or if you wanna you can immediately
force uh a draw here with queen to g8
you can't go to f5 because you lose the
pawn and if you go king to h uh six then
queen h8 you threaten the f6 pawn and
now there's
well not all that uh
much black can do here to defend okay
you can go rook to f4 uh but safest is
just to go for a nice repetition here
king h6 queen to h8 um
and and get a draw uh fabi uh not
interested in this plays king to h2 and
now we have queen to e7 uh making this
move 39 so one more move has to be made
to reach time control and fabi has like
two and a half minutes to make it and
it's an incredibly intense position you
have to be very very careful uh one
thing you could of course do is queen to
g8 we already discussed this but fabi
plays pawn to g3
uh and this allows abdusathorov to just
go for for the attack and he does he
plays h4 so how do you play this queen
to g8 with check king to h6 now king to
g2 and here uh we have pawn to f5 and
this is basically where abdusatrov loses
all of his advantage and everyone was
criticizing him for making this move
against fabi uh but as you'll see it's
not all that clear even the great
fabiano corona falters in this position
he does find queen to c8 which is the
strongest reply now having access to
rook to d7
but after h characters on g3 you have to
continue playing precise moves uh but
here fabi plays queen captures on f5 and
he blunders the game completely now the
thing how you hold this is rook to d7
that's how you do it and after queen to
eight offering a queen trade queen
capture sun b7 going after the h67 pawn
uh and this is basically a draw g
captures an f2 you're gonna capture on
h7 king g5 queen to g7 check now you can
block with queen to g6 captures captures
and now let's say rook to a7 and okay
black is up two pawns but only for the
moment this is a draw for example rook
f4 uh we're going to capture this with
check if king g5 king f1 we stop the
pawn now it's a double spawn so
not all that great uh but like i said uh
queen captures an f5 was played instead
and this would work if there was not
that one annoying move that wins the
game for abdusatorov so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this incredible idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not grabbing the
pawn that
wouldn't be all that great if you grab
the pawn then you allow rook to h1 with
check and then you're never gonna win
this um
or you know you're gonna have to
accept a pretty much an immediate draw
however if you found rook to h4 then you
are truly an incredible player as this
is the only move that wins the game for
abdu santorov this is what he played and
now what do you play the problem is if
you go rook to d7 now which was always a
good idea if the queen moves you can get
uh you can actually checkmate the black
king the problem is rook h2 check and
now after king capture sun g3 queen h4
check and now you just get checkmated
queen a king of three rook cat person f2
the white queen falls uh and that's it
uh so unfortunately for fabi he cannot
do that he has to play king captures on
g3 uh but now comes rook to h5
everything with tempo not allowing any
checks and not allowing uh
this rook lift and the problem is now
you have to do something because if
queen h4 lands then it's game over uh so
queen to f4 would check but now
abdusathrov just plays queen g5 blocks
check and forks forces a queen trade and
the rook and pawn end game does seem to
be winning for him so queen g4 he forces
the trade captures captures and the rook
the g5 check king f4 and the rook
captures an a5 he's now up to pawns uh
rook to d6 would check with king to h5
and rook to d7 fabi will win back at
least one of those pawns so rook b5 and
now rook captures an h7 with check king
g6 rook the c7 going after this pawn but
now rook captures and b2 and now it
doesn't matter if you capture this we
capture here with check two connected
past pawns of course this is completely
winning both of them know this so after
king to e5 b5 defending the pawn fabie
tries at least okay maybe i can push my
pass pawn and then again some counter
play rook c6 check king to h5 now pawn
to f4 with a5 the race is on point f5
pawn to a4 and now if you uh if you go
upon to f6 then king here the king
guards the f7 square so fabi has to try
something different rook the c8 we have
ponta a3 rook to h8 with check now king
to g5 rook g8 check king to h6 here we
have pawn to f6 and here rook to f2 and
he was in this position on move 61 that
fabiano corona resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
three pass pawns connected pass pawns
are just two too
too much for example if king e6
a2 pawn to f7 you don't really care you
you can just bring a queen into the game
and if five brings the queen into the
game you just take it and that's it you
have a rook and two pawns a queen and
two pawns against the rook of course uh
completely winning so uh really a wild
game where it's interesting that okay
fabio of course is almost a hundred high
rating points higher rated than
abdusatrov and of course he wanted to
push for a win he tried basically
everything from the opening choice the
avoiding uh drawbar repetition many
times throughout the game
and even his team was winning um
as wesley won that game very nicely uh
but there was a problem on one of the
boards sam shanklin was completely lost
on board four against the akongir
vakidov uh and that's probably why fabi
pushed for a win uh so the united states
could get uh a win but in the end it's
fabi who lost this game and shankland
managed to get a draw on board four so
uh the clash united states versus
uzbekistan ends in a draw with two draws
and two uh decisive games but you know
that's uh that's why team events are
always very very volatile and
the games are uh very interesting
because who knows how this game might
have ended up if it was you know just a
one-on-one and not a team event but um
you know uh
you know at the end of the day uh it is
abdusatro who takes down fabiana karwana
in classical chess
uh so uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it big congratulations to
uzbekistan and this uh well i'm gonna
call it a victory even though the match
ended in a draw uh i would like to thank
david kimura
jacob tobias for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to cover the games from
the olympiad until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day